e
vero che lo stesso g nuovissima
avventura rob lowe curiosi giochi più
popolare in assoluto sul blog è una
storia che vivremo assieme
non ho idea di cosa succederà non ho
idea del perché sia il gioco ma ciò che
più popolare in assoluto su robot lo
scopriremo per lui che cosa che so è che
ci sono dei cattivi o ci saranno dei
cattivi non so quando non so come mai li
diamo subito prezzo vero che anche l'eco
città sono io la sostano piccolina
perché abbiamo deciso di mettere la
versione piccolini per pesata signora
dice che dobbiamo esplorare la casa
proviamo si chiama brake in settori il
che mi fa pensare forse entreranno dei
ladri uno dice ehi benvenuto nella sua
nuova casa giocatori mentre la nostra
nuova casa ci sono vari snack in giro
perché si daranno un po di energia
adriana mi piace mangiare esplora mia
casa di questo mangiandola me la gara
sembra tutto tranquillo in serie
dovrebbe essere una storia un po paurosa
ma finora è tutto ok ma c'è una stanza
tutta rosa che permette con questo
perché il mio personaggio in miniatura
quando sono andato ad accarezzare il
gatto mi ha tolto 10 punti
possibili aspetti ha graffiato è il
maestro dormendo stavolta a dormire dice
ma è tutto così tranquillo quando
inizieranno a succedere le cose strane
no vabbè ho trovato un biscotto
se andiamo a vedere vitali cosa sta
facendo molto bene vitale ha trovato la
chiave del sotterraneo
veramente andiamo ad aprirlo rai.tv 1 su
rig è sicuramente il gattone graffiato
perché ho dei graffi sulla faccia ehi ma
che stai facendo la dieta
dobbiamo andare a trovare il
cantino e sotterraneo come si chiama di
cui trovato la chiave
preghiamo facendo una mappa aiuta la
chiave aspetta
come facciamo da davide è un po alto per
entrare dice servono ma scarpi
sta iniziando a succedere qualcosa
sedetevi nel tavolo la cena verrà
servita fraisse ok ok io sono sedute qua
capotavola io sono qui affiatate che
piccolini che stiamo e gli altri
giocatori ancora non sono arrivati
cosa succederà adesso
e perché quel giocatore laggiù con la
mazza
qualcuno sta mangiando delle patatine
608 vero io
viene mangiando una mela
comprese quelle cose
vabbè io ho già chiamato il frigo
ma qualcuna è la porta e si è andata a
campionare controllo ad aprire la porta
anita ho aperto la porta la pizza
ha
anche preso le figlie per favore portale
di ciò chiediamo la porta ok abbiamo
subito tre reti per le pizze il nome di
pizzo sono più grandi delle altre ma io
ho preso tutto è un problema fretta ok
ho mangiato una fetta di pizza che
succede secondo me dovremmo andare a
controllare un po in giro per vedere se
solo dall'altro ci fu menta vado bene
battibile no no no 4 po come sta
succedendo qualcosa era questa la porta
quindi io direi di aprire ma ad aprirla
una porta chiusa vita nella chiave dai
aprile ok cercando
che succede è
troppo è troppo
invece
no perché è diventato tutto io non
riesco mi sono bloccato che sono
riusciti ed e dice che fra poco ci sarà
un annuncio
ok ma possiamo trovarci che succede
emergenza
trasmissioni di maria
i cattivi sono liberi
non interagire con loro verrà il sito
questa non è una prova sono molto
pericolosi
si accorse che a volte neanche le
finestre il loro leader tornando il
curry se provi a combattere verrai
sconfitto andiamo a chiedere tutela
parte chiave sbrigati ora di andare a
dormire ho
sentito sulle reti di energia aiuto al
suo odio energia è meglio andare a
dormire perché potevo mangiare ma
cattivi o di buongiorno mi perché io si
addormento e sto ricaricando le energie
i cattivi
credo credo router o dove scappare tutto
che no ma quello lo ammazzano può
aiutarci aiuto ios capperi
sotto il letto
supportando
già morta no io sono vivo che se c'è da
chiudere la finestra vedi la stanza blu
blu è stata attaccata ma siamo tutti
sopravvissuti ma che fortuna anche la
stanza rosa è stata attaccata e tutti
sono sopravvissuti meno male stanno
arrivando a prenderci non possiamo fare
in modo che ci attacchino di nuovo al
nostro delle delle tavole nella stanza
principale
dobbiamo serrare ogni finestra che porta
qui qui bravata ma vai avanti dato che
qui per te la puoi prendere vedere ok
prendiamole iniziamo a coprire ogni bene
ha fatto a prendere quota
ok
ne ho messo un bel po non penso che
riusciranno più a passare stanotte
possiamo dormire tranquilli qua auto lei
coperta benissimo in un po così così
scopre che bene altrimenti riusciranno
ad entrare
bene direi che abbiamo fatto il massimo
la cosa si sta già facendo buio pagarsi
dove legittimamente
trova gli interruttori della luce ai 20
secondi stanza per uscire cosa
potevano trovare l'interruttore per
levarlo diabetica di ok eccone uno ma io
non ce l'ho fatta
mi dice che ho fatto un lavoro ok non
vedo nessun altro il trattore a dice che
abbiamo fatto quelle che questo quelli
che hanno fatto di più per proteggere la
casa io e te
meno male che succede wow è già tardi
hawks ci sono tre pezzi di pizza rimasti
ok prendiamoli
amico ora dobbiamo tenerci
non prendere mai
incontrato di nuovo
tra di successo hanno già tolto alla
luce da dove arriva quella luce e guardo
il mondo ricordo
per una macchina forse mi ricordo dove è
la scala è qui che vada a dormire sono
pure ieri come sei fuori loro sono amori
io sono nella stanza blu e sto dormendo
dobbiamo sperare che queste cliniche
abbiamo messo
ci protegga sono riusciti a sopravvivere
la notte o qualcuno ha tratto dove
aiuto che antea è tutto buio non si vede
niente riusciti a passare sì non ci
chiama per un fosso a sopravvivere
queste sbarre ci hanno aiutato al piano
di sotto e crollare le porte alle
finestre e porte finestre ma stai
attento che tagliamo
dobbiamo fare esattamente hanno rotto
una polo una finestra qui o no dobbiamo
ripararla vitale ha trovato la finestra
rotta scantinato lo scantinato è stato
lasciato aperto
quello che vuoi quei cattivi se ne
ascoltano spiegato come facciamo adesso
dobbiamo andare là dove mandarlo via
immagino sembra logica enormi nasconditi
nella pagina o che vi preghiamo si
dovrebbe poter escludere quindi ho
guidato
bene
non lo so siamo nascosti dentro un
armadio che si tenta un ben più
piccolo è stato schiera larry il loro
capo e ora che facciamo meglio rimanere
nella madre forse è meglio di sé
arrivando qua sente parte noi per
fortuna siamo nascosti e codice è andato
al piano di sopra che presto
attivato in modo da avere uno scatto in
atmosfera
e qua e qua corre è quello che voleva
capire come ma chi per formare un
comitato nazionale se c'è anche detto
che no no io non lo tocchiamo il gatto
una mela un martello qualche la
preghiera forse per difendersi dal
prezzo io ci credo ho trovato altri
soldi e ora anche dobbiamo fare che non
arrivi qua a questa è la scala che ci
servirà per sopra bravo quelle per
salire in soffitta sente che offrendo
l'asta me l'ha mai lasciata aperta come
ho lasciato la porta per ora sarà ancora
più difficile
penso che dobbiamo combattere prendete
qualcosa per combattere io su questa
scala si può usare la scala perché anche
lì
difendi
stanno cercando di entrare difendi
difendila scantinato si sa il forcone
sto difendendo con lo scatenato dove tu
non lo so
ah ho capito
ricordiamolo questo compito questo col
petto
ed attento e che si sta prendendo anche
a te ti stai facendo però allontana di
sto difendendo io no no morto vitale
morpho spero che riesce a tornare mai
detto sono gli hai fatto ti faccio
vedere io come
attentato
o no anch'io sono o no aspetta aspetta
questo visto che sta grado di un
domenico mio dovere per chi a tutt'e due
questi sono troppo forti
troppo
innamorato ad aiutarci aspetta stereo ad
hoc
vediamo vediamo se resto eliminare da
sola anche più sarà molto difficile
prendetevi better quest'effetto andate
via per sempre via ma quanti sono perché
sono dato una
anche tu sei morta disagio purtroppo
stiamo morti stefano e ci hanno
eliminato quelli cattivi con nessuno in
più sono rimasta poi io da sola e quindi
abbiamo dovuto ricominciare da capo ma
questa volta giocheremo tutti e due con
il mio personaggio così forse riso ma
unire le forze e a farsela vediamo
questa volta non mi dimenticherò la
porta si è aperta così forse se non
entrano riusciamo ad andare avanti
avete lasciato mi piace se questo video
raggiunge i 10 mila mi piace fare una
seconda parte quindi mi raccomando
lasciate un bel mi piace qua sotto
stanno arrivando
andiamo a sedersi al tavolo troppo corri
veron che prima notte dovrebbero già
arrivare dalla prima notte sto cercando
di recuperare le energie nel letto nè di
multe arriveranno me tra l'altro tu sei
proprio vicino alla finestra sì infatti
perché doveva avere questo lento io
mangerete aiuto aiuto aiuto
svegliatevi il 70
aiuto aiuto aiuto non lo stanno
attaccando perché parola difensore è
viva grazie per avermi protesta adulti
tutti sono sopravvissuti vediamo nella
blue room anche nella stanza blu sono
sopravvissuti tutti
ora è meglio che ci proteggiamo come
prima princesa notte le sbarre che
chiediamo bene questa volta non lascia
voleva piffero gazzi non entreranno
perché dovevano esserci delle finestre
così gradi dai prendi delle altre delle
altre asse di legno e vai a proteggere
le finestre sotto forse questa volta
andrà meglio dai fine questa questa che
dove è entrato l'altra volta
brava anche questa fianco sbrigati e non
l'infinito devi prendere le altre cose
non ricordo e se gli sbrigati
aiuto ma
la
veloce veloce no no
hai fatto un ottimo lavoro dice enzo
tardi che stanno arrivando dovete più a
votare dobbiamo andare lì e solidi tra
per servizi rimasti hanno preso la
chiave dello scantinato come l'hanno
ancora aperto no è piovuto a questo fine
tra entreranno
sono fuori nono cabiate thereau voglio
fare questa la carta che le assi di
legno ci proteggano vai a dormire
proteggiti amici
ok ti ma perché proprio in questa
coincidenza autore entreranno da questa
finestra dice tutto fuori dalla finestra
bellico race le immagini della maschera
e diliberto non ci sono tre davanti sono
tre hanno qualcosa
mi vedete qualcosa in mano forse sono
andati via si stanno attuando noto
nitrati l'aiuto degli ottimi svegliatevi
non puoi dormire
solo di no nell'altra stanza si stanno
se facciamo questi sta mandando
finalmente a prenderti ad aiutare no no
hanno fatto eliminato un giocatore
rimasti il 3 la stanza era stato
attaccato l'altra notte nessuno insomma
se io ho vissuto qui si sa se solo in
tre
le assi di legno non erano abbastanza
papa per trattenerle ma poi alla fine
sono andati via prendi la mazza prendi
una mazza così ti puoi difendere qui ok
va bene se di andare al piano di sotto e
controllare sono entrati dalla finestra
la cantina come prima questa volta forse
ce la facciamo vediamo nascondi
nascondiamoci nascondiamoci lei almeno 6
con 2 adulti ma forse riuscito a
difendermi tutti e tra pieri hanno preso
l'altro siamo rimasti in due non ce la
faremo mai è andato quindi sopra presto
va in cabina
e merkel arriva l'altro è rimasto lì beh
è troppo forte perché sei piccoletta la
mazza da baseball e gigante del chiese
la porta questa volta la roche l'altro
quando arriverà ti ricorderà di
rinchiuderla monforte sarò io da sola io
ti consiglio di prevedere anche la mazza
bisogna solo perché selezionata fra
chiuso la porta andiamo a controllare
nola la tana ma ci credo
prepariamoci al combattimento sono
arrivando
per i motivi mi aiuti devi difendere
arrivano
non è facile no per mia perfetto brava
no line up no l'aveva battuto tipo io
faccio dall'altro sono tantissimi
impossibile sono troppi
non vorrei dire ma prova avete eliminate
6 la finanza si aspetta in è arrivato un
altro
non c'è qualcosa da mangiare no non sono
in due
o non colpito lui per sbaglio
non sono in tre a device possibile
voluto solo
siamo molto rea di guala novi è stato
difficilissimo non ci credo che perdono
glielo devo riusciti a respingerli se
volete il continuo però lasciato mi
piace e se questo video senza 10.000
silvio ci proveremo di nuovo a
respingere il ladro cosa sono a che ha
un non so cosa siano voi reso tu mi
piace anzi se avete completato il gioco
la fazi vostri consigli qui e ora vi
lasciamo con quattro cartellini e su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite buona
visione